salut toi tu veux ça mais ça
tu veux ça
fais ça
fait ça
alors n'oublie jamais si tu le veux tu
le peux
et
je des numéros 9 1867 au départ de paris
gare de lyon et à destination de
perpignan n'arrivera jamais à
destination
veuillez terminer le voyage à pied la
sncf vous souhaite une bonne
continuation
[Musique]
[Rires]
johnny d'être couche devant l'impôt
c'est incroyable
je suis abasourdi
je me mélange monde
jenny pique au jeu comme
m
c'est mon pays
mais
je suis avec anita
attention alors ne parle pas du tout
français avait dit youssouf et amis ok
ok go est lui totalement folle de soi un
jacques sommes prêts nous sommes prêts à
tout avant le 20 avr non mais c'est le
cadet n'a pas dit que n'en revient à
temps
c'est quoi la météo préféré des
dépressifs
quand il pleut des cordes
erdan je ne t'ai pas pour toi c'est
domec qui discutent nains qui demande
entre tu sais c'est quoi le chef-lieu
des deux sèvres si señor pardon je parle
pas espagnol